día tras día el fenómeno se repite
alumnas de escuelas femeninas en Irán
inhalan olores descritos como
desagradables o desconocidos y luego
presentan síntomas como náuseas disnea o
mareos en su primera reacción pública de
la ayatola Ali cundeó firmemente estos
actos llegaron los perpetradores deben
ser condenados a un Severo castigo ese
es un crimen grave e imperdonable no
habrá amnistía para ellos
desde noviembre las autoridades han
registrado presuntos ataques en más de
50 escuelas de 25 de las 31 provincias
yranías y según un recuento oficial ya
sería unas mil las colegiadas afectadas
los incidentes han desencadenado una ola
de indignación y de temor en todo el
país así como reiteradas exigencias al
ejecutivo para que tome medidas
concretas
no debería permitirse que este tipo de
cosas les ocurran los niños en estos
tiempos
pido al gobierno que actúe con rapidez
para proteger las vidas de la próxima
generación todas las madres de Irán
están angustiadas por los
envenenamientos
el viceministro de sanidad dijo que los
presuntos ataques tenían como objetivo
interrumpir la educación de las niñas
actividad achacada grupos extremistas
algunas alumnas son hospitalizadas
brevemente Pero según las autoridades
ninguna ha resultado gravamente afectada
hasta el momento mientras la
investigación para determinar de qué
substancia se trata continua la policía
iraní aumentó este lunes la presencia de
patrullas en los centros educativos
femeninos lo que no ha evitado nuevos
casos de intoxicaciones